the trial of a white police officer
charged with murdering a black teenager
resumes today after the defendant made
an unexpected appearance on the witness
stand Jason van Dyke testified in his
own defense yesterday in a Chicago
courtroom now he claims he shot 17
year-old laQuan McDonald back in 2014
because the teenager was threatening him
with a knife Dean Reynolds is outside
the courthouse where Van Dyke faces two
counts of first-degree murder and a
possible life sentence Dean good morning
good morning back in 2014 October of
2014 Van Dyke and his partner responded
to a call about a man with a knife
breaking into vehicles six seconds after
arriving on the scene van Dyke fired off
16 shots killing laQuan McDonald and
yesterday on the witness stand a
combative and at times emotional Van
Dyke recounted events of that day the
space had no expression his eyes were
just bugging out of his head he had just
these huge white eyes just staring right
through me with the help of defense
attorney Randy Rucker Jason van Dyke
walked the jury through his version of
the moments leading up to the deadly
2014 shooting I was yelling at him drop
the knife I don't know how many times
but that's all I and he never stopped
but even the defense's own animation and
the dashcam video do not show McDonald
advancing toward Van Dyke or any of the
other seven officers at the scene he
waived the knife from his lower right
side upwards cross his body towards my
left shoulder and when he did that what
did you do officer I shot him
Tuesday's testimony also included some
theatrics from the defense use of force
expert very broad acted out how little
time officer van Dyke would supposedly
have had to react to a possible knife
attack from McDonald
during cross-examination prosecutor Jody
Gleeson attacked officer van Dyke story
and in that six seconds he got a lot
closer to me than I ever could have
gotten away from him around the squad
car van Dyke testified that he shot at
McDonald's knife until he dropped it but
Gleeson rejected that explanation you're
not trained as a police officer to shoot
at somebody's knife are you no you're
not
McDonald's death led to massive protests
and political action including the
firing of the city's police
superintendent and on Tuesday Chicago's
Civil Rights icon the Reverend Jesse
Jackson demanded justice justice and
peace go hand in hand and the once
there's no justice no peace there must
be a some mass action if justice is not
printed
defense attorneys may wrap up their case
this morning and closing arguments are
expected later this week Viana dean
thank you